Also ja, ein Lebenstipp, den ich
kürzlich entdeckt habe und ich finde, dass er
in jeder schwierigen Situation hilft. Es
klingt offensichtlich, aber nur ein
paar tiefe Atemzüge zu nehmen. Ich denke, wir vergessen, wenn
wir etwas Schwieriges tun, wenn
wir gestresst sind  Wenn uns etwas
stört, vergessen wir oft zu atmen,
und ich denke, Sie wissen, ob es die
Nervosität ist, bevor ich auf die Bühne gehe oder bevor
ich ein schwieriges Gespräch mit
jemandem
habe  denke,
viele Konflikte könnten
mit nur einer kurzen Pause gelöst werden, bevor wir handeln, also
ja, das wäre mein
Tipp, es hilft beim Autofahren, es hilft am
Arbeitsplatz, es hilft beim Liebesspiel, Kochen,
was auch immer es sein mag, es ist es, es
wird überall angewendet  Der Vorstand ja Onkel
Marlon rät allen zu Hause
, tief Luft zu holen